last year we took a giant robot to
comic-con the ultimate walk around
cosplay robot and he became one of the
big hits of comic the idea obviously is
to be bigger and better and more
innovative and kick last year's butt so
let's jump into creative build
discussions now following on the heels
of last year's we want to be bigger in
presentation you know that expectation
can be high it's got to be mobile
portability mobility you've got to be
able to get it in around easily
throughout the event and lots of fun
tech Wow we always have to remember this
is wired what we love or love that so
and another key member of the team is
here is Stratos a world leader in the
Stan Winston school of character arts
and us that's what we do is create
character so that's got to be paramount
now comes the fun part all the legacy
effects artists are gonna reach the
creature
so we did this like really ferocious
imposing thing but then his chest would
open up and it would reveal a cat chick
hi how are you seeing that moving around
I was just imagining it built on a frame
with bicycle wheels so they could have a
couple guys pushing around inside in
between Bionic and the mechanic sure how
so chrome insect Obot my original
profile was sort of monkeyish and then
it sort of went be Kish as I was
sketching it if it was more monkeyish
than you could actually include live
articulation and if you wanted to stay
away from someone like Jim said some of
the problems you get with the
particulate exterior deep space for a
star-filled support vehicle to be
dressed up too part of the performance
so you can get the performer around the
con easily enough you can see from the
side here we got two puppeteers the guy
on top does the arms the guy in the
bottom can either drive a cart or you
can manipulate the head all the
portholes and windows in there we could
have as a double pane glass or plac seat
and have little bubbles coming up
through it trying to make tech and
organic work at once this was a low of a
mechanical bunny and that lots of lights
worried things spending things because
he's a big hopper so I was thinking this
thing here could open up Ken he's clad
in some sort of armor he's not Oliver
he's hidden inside of a dome so it
reveals him so he's the Barker he's the
guy at King Kong's like come see the
monster come see the show these legs are
articulated that could potentially be
three to four feet tall retro Victorian
steampunk robot that's like a war
machine the thing he's pushing right
there would be a vortex cannon they've
had done some concepts for driving
armored or fully metallic each one
innovative different some have wheels
some could fly so much stories and
scripts there was one design that sort
of stood above the rest bigger badder
so we won they love our stuff they like
it that's what really kind of blew
everyone away was just getting the scale
and having that like how the hell is
that working
you're never gonna imagine or three
people in their house maybe I make sure
that this will actually work but we're
back to the drawing board want to see
more go to wired.com for the entire
giant creature suit
you